hi there Steve coffin here going to talk
today about the proficiency in foreign
languages levels of proficiency or
levels of fluency and I'm going I'm
doing this in response to a video that I
just watched which features Luka who in
my mind is I'm absolutely outstanding
polyglot and Anthony louder from Prague
by the way if you enjoy these videos
where I talk about language learning
please subscribe to my channel umm now
the video and I'll post a link to it in
the description box is a discussion
between as I say Luca and Anthony where
they sort of make the point that you
don't need to have a large vocabulary in
order to be fluent and the Anthony has
in the past sort of said that even with
a few hundred words you can be fluent or
you can be fluent at a relatively low
level of proficiency in a language I
don't agree at all first of all let's
look at this word fluency fluency is a
bit like the word good or well you know
you can say I'm if you say I'm fluent in
a language that actually means that you
are very fluent if you say I speak a
language well it means that you speak it
well if you say I speak the language
quite well or I'm quite fluent that
suggests actually something less than
fluency and so if you are able to say a
few things in the language you might
even suggest that I'm sort of fairly
fluent in the language but that's to my
mind less than fluent so in the video
they both talked about how you know
Anthony can go around town and in Prague
and doesn't need many words to you know
have exchanged pleasantries with
shopkeepers or whatever but is this
really fluency I don't think so
there are different ways of measuring
you know
was a proficiency in a language there's
the European common framework of
reference which divides proficiency into
six levels from a1 a2 b1 b2 c1 c2 in my
view b2 is where you are fluent so
that's actually fairly far along and in
order to be fluent you have to be able
to do certain things I think you have to
be able to read a newspaper now in
Chinese that might cause some difficulty
because the writing system isn't
phonetic so conceivably you could be
fluent and not be able to read the
newspaper but in most situations someone
who is fluent in a language should be
able to read the newspaper the newspaper
typically I know in English the the sort
of difficulty level is roughly grade 7
grade 8 and the biggest factor in the
difficulty level of any content is the
vocabulary level and now granted you
could have complex sentences and complex
structures but I think the main
difference in particular we're talking
about levels of fluency is how complex
or how you know sort of how many
relatively less frequent words are used
I think one in order to be able to call
oneself fluent one needn't be able to
read you know esoteric literature or
scientific papers but one should be able
to read the newspaper and to read the
newspaper you do need at least the
vocabulary of someone in grade 7 and
that's a third number of words I think
it's I think they talked about I don't
know it's got to be 7 or 8 9 10 thousand
words in English and course the other
thing is if we're talking about levels
of proficiency or levels of fluency in
the language so then I also think that
the biggest indicator is the number of
words you know so if you are very fluent
and
if you are at a university level you are
going to know a lot more words than
someone who can only read at a grade 3
level now you could argue that someone
could be fluent with a limited
vocabulary and it's possible that one
could be fluent with a grade 3 level of
vocabulary but if you are an adult and
you can only communicate with children
then to my mind you're less than fluent
if you can only talk about the weather
and talk about very basic things even if
you do so fluently to my mind you're not
fluent the native speaker most native
speakers most adult native speakers have
a large vocabulary a large active
vocabulary perhaps the people certainly
the people that I would like to
communicate with have large active
vocabulary therefore I have to have a
fairly large passive vocabulary in order
to understand what they're saying and I
think that fluency implies two-way
communication you can learn a bunch of
sentences you can use Anki or whatever
to express yourself fairly quickly but
the trick is to understand what other
people are saying and that is why I put
so much emphasis on listening and
reading and you can see in the
background here just some of the
language CDs that I own and I have books
and I find the daily I download content
from the internet and I listen now much
of this you know issue of fluency it
also depends on on what your needs are
and so if you have a need to communicate
right away now because you're in the
country and you're going to the stores
and the shops there's going to be more
pressure on you to speak in my case as I
call it dilettante language learner I'm
quite content to let my vocabulary
accumulate and my ability to understand
develop until such a time as I have a
need or an opportunity to speak a lot
and then my speaking develops quite
quickly now there are people who
understand
well and who are too shy or inhibited to
speak I think those people are the
minority I think once people have
acquired a good understanding of the
language they generally have the
vocabulary and therefore the confidence
that they can start to develop the
ability to speak so that's my view on
Luka and Anthony's video I don't agree
with them
I think fluency if we're talking about
not quite or somewhat fluent if we're
talking about really fluent then that
requires a large vocabulary thank you
for listening bye for now oh and an
afterthought until you are fluent in the
language you should probably read
whatever you listen to and listen to
what you read I mean the foreign
language CDs you see in the background
as much as possible I try to find the
text so that I can learn the words so
with that in mind you'll be able to if
you're a student of English you'll be
able to find this video with the
transcript as a lesson at Linc and we
will put up a link in the description
box I just want to add that thank you
bye
you